in the lobby of Ramsey solutions they're
here Manny and Mary are with us hey guys
how are you hey good how you doing
better than I deserve welcome welcome
what do you guys live in Deanna fun good
to have you guys welcome to Nashville
into a rain storm today that's right no
laughs but anyway cool good to have you
so you're here to do your debt-free
screen we are I love it how much have
you paid off seventy-two thousand one
hundred eighty dollars good for you and
how long did that take six months Wow
okay range of income during that time
we're about a 130-135 okay
working lots of jobs gotcha what do
y'all do for a living I'm a social
worker and I'm a police officer
oh very good very cool so what kind of
debt was the $70,000 this was my wife Oh
me mana you just threw her on the bus
man bus tracks right there you know I
knew that one Mary Mary what did you buy
a master's degree in social work
oh my goodness okay so it did you sell
stuff to get out of that this fast cuz
you did this really fast yeah we sold my
house oh there's always a I sold right
well it wasn't that much of the house
but we sold that older cars
I know daga do to make sure that she got
her dream of getting out of this debt
okay very cool many many jobs so the
house was a second house or no we just
got married a year ago in February oh
yeah oh okay
so right after you get married she says
we're getting out of debt and man he
says all right yeah that's whatever we
got to do you sold your house so where
are you living her house so how much of
the 70,000 got knocked out when your
house got sold roughly about Phoebe
split about $15,000 down okay and then
after we started multiplying it more
mowing your teachings are mhmmm we can
just knocked everything out six months
ago put everything towards it cool also
sold my car in the process our car we
had your car bring about what's at 14-14
though yeah
thirty thousand of the seventy was those
two things yeah and then you had forty
two still do in six months that's still
rowdy yeah I mean y'all are still on the
game I mean it's game on here you were
really doing it congratulations very
cool so um you had a dream of being out
of debt after you get out of school what
made what lets you own fire for that
Mary well I have a pretty significant
number to share that I think speaks a
lot about our student loan debt crisis
and you speak often about it and I'm
pretty passionate about it now I
graduated with my Master's in May of
2008 and then August of 2015 were newly
married and my in that time frame from
May of 2008 to August of 2015 my
principal on that loan had only gone
down six hundred and twenty-eight
dollars paying minimum payments right
Yeah right you were spinning your wheels
right that that pretty well sickened me
in seven years
yes oh my gosh so that had been there a
while yeah that was a weight weighing on
me for a long time and so you guys
decide to get married and you guys start
looking at and you say these numbers
work if we if we work yeah we came
together I remember there was one
morning we we got up we were still in
bed and we got the patent paper out and
we put our heads together and we said
okay you know if we do this if we do
that if we follow this plan if we follow
this budget we realized we could do this
and we first thought a year and then
realizing if we threw I got rid of my
car and started driving a beater if you
know we worked our extra jobs and we
actually got it done in six months yeah
that that one morning with a yellow pad
changed your whole life yeah I remember
the hope just washing over me I mean I
thought I would die with this loan I
mean I unfortunately believe a lot
America believes that you have to take
your student loans to the grave yeah and
you don't you just have to have a plan
and a passion to go with the plan and I
hope that watches over to you that
causes that that's that's very cool go
ahead so what do you tell people that
the key to getting out of debt in this
case student loan debt seventy thousand
dollars and six months is well a lot of
hard work not working sacrifice is what
it took it for us you know they
understand that you couldn't live the
lifestyle you had
for mm-hmm and continue and pay anything
off real right so we just had just a
buckle down and say you know what we may
have those things later on but for right
now this what we have to what what's the
craziest thing you cut out of your
budget
the one thing you weren't really I was
high buying more weapons for myself get
to lower the gun envelope being married
to a police officer always a gun I have
the same addiction it's okay my name is
David how about too many guns okay good
for you guys that's hard I mean whatever
it is that your love and your hobby and
the thing you've got some passion about
to stop that in order to have a goal you
know Earl Nightingale used to say it's
not what you're willing to do to hit
your goals it's what you're willing to
not do it causes you to hit your goals
the things you're willing to take off
the plate and give you room to win so
you guys are very very impressive thank
you for making the trip all the way to
Nashville today debt-free scream thank
you for having us enjoy some here's a
wonderful town to visit we just want to
thank God if we could for given this
opportunity to you know give us the
means to pay this off for no forget amen
amen very cool all right
Manny and Mary Fort Wayne Indiana
$70,000 paid off in six months making
130 to 135 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one we're
debt-free
great job very very very well done I
love it
congratulations hey you guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the Dave
Ramsey channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you